london is the second largest city in
europe and
underneath this bustling city is one of
the oldest and largest networks of train
tunnels
in the world but that's not the only
huge old structure
located beneath the city of london below
even the deepest underground
metro stations of this historic city
there's a whole artificial world of
surveillance cyborgs
impossible architecture and stomach
churning nutritional
supplements so be sure to mind the gap
because we're about
to take you on a tour of scp-1678
also known as unlondon scp-1678 is
located one kilometer below the city of
london england
from all appearances it seems to be an
exact copy of the city
though aesthetically it's more in line
with how it was around the turn of the
20th century
gas streetlights stand on every corner
and the modern skyscrapers of the
business district are recreated in the
style of victorian architecture
the epicenter of construction appears to
be the houses of parliament
which is evidenced by the more
unfinished and flawed the city becomes
further out from the center one goes
some of the buildings are made of
nonsensical materials like copper pipes
and some of the gas lamps are nothing
more than a ball of disembodied light
floating atop
a metal pole the first big question that
the foundation had
upon discovering this location was of
course
why on earth was it created and they
wouldn't have to look
far as an explanation of this bizarre
mirror city plays automatically upon
entering
my fellow citizen if you are hearing
this tape
then the world as we know it is finished
the sky
has broken the ground heaves with a
[ __ ] of terrible feet
and all the horror and madness from the
dark corners of the world has broken
free to exact its vengeance on the world
of man
evil has raised its bloody flag upon all
nations of the world
and crowd its unholy victory to the
broken sky
yes this is the end but there is a new
hope
welcome to unlondon a city of survivors
a city of the free together fellow
citizen we will wait and prepare for the
new beginning
the grand new world that is soon to come
let the world above burn we will endure
that the monsters have the world we will
prepare
we will wait and i tell you citizen that
there will be a new morning
and you will emerge from unlondon and
stand blinking in the sun
and on that day citizen there shall be a
new order as we raise the union flag
over the entire world
i welcome you to one london the last
city
and the first from this message it seems
that this mirror city was built to be a
refuge for survivors of an apocalyptic
scenario
but the scp foundation had no knowledge
of such a plan
in fact it's still unknown who created
this place
or how they did it the one fact that was
evident to the foundation was that even
though this strange place was intended
to be a safe haven
it was far too poorly constructed to
actually act as one
illumination was unreliable and most of
the buildings were damp and infested
with mold
it's also unclear to the foundation
where the oxygen and gas supply of
unlondon was coming from
throughout the day the loudspeakers
around on london play automated messages
such as
no one is safe from the influence of
mimetic beings
bryson's home for the poor is here to
help and
crime will not be tolerated in on london
the tormentors of society will become
its defenders at the end of every hour
that passes
the speakers announced the time followed
by and
all is well when the scp foundation
first entered on london
it was unknown whether or not any living
things inhabited the city
on first investigation it seemed from
its state of disrepair that the city had
been long
abandoned but soon the foundation met
their first inhabitant of the
underground
city mobile task force members were
inspecting the area around the houses of
parliament
when they discovered what looked to be a
bank as they approached the doors
they heard the following announcement
over the nearby loudspeakers
citizen you are entering a restricted
area
have your authorization papers ready a
bobby will arrive to escort you shortly
this signaled the approach of scp-1678-a
also known as the bobbies a single
instance of scp-1678-a
appeared with the unmistakable sound of
a police whistle
and as soon as it arrived it started
attacking the members of the task force
another announcement came over the
speakers police halt
criminal the bobbies are the main threat
to visitors in on london
and they will attack on-site with any
improvised weapon they can find
true to their name they are all dressed
in uniforms consistent with those of
london city police officers from the
victorian
era what sets them apart from their
historical counterparts
is their construction these beings are
made out of human corpses
crudely dismembered at the joints and
reassembled using metal hinges and bolts
with their heads wrapped in bandages
bobbies are extremely hard to kill
with only high caliber rounds and
explosive weapons being effective at
putting them down
autopsies of dead bobbies have shown
that underneath the police uniform
the bobbies all wear prison inmate style
jumpsuits
this adds a chilling context to the
announcement about the tormentors of
society becoming its defenders
it appears that the bobbies are the
re-animated bodies
of prisoners in addition to the bobbies
the foundation catalogued two additional
forms of artificial life present within
on london first are scp-1678-p
or eyes in the sky hybrid biomechanical
birds made of flesh with an exoskeleton
of copper wiring
some of these creatures are covered in a
deteriorating outer layer of plastic and
feathers
suggesting that they were originally
meant to resemble pigeons
as their name suggests eyes in the sky
serve as a type of surveillance drone
and while they have no offensive
capabilities they still pose a
significant threat to the foundation
it's still unclear whether they're able
to communicate with or summon the
bombies
but the scp foundation takes no chances
the last life form present in scp-1678
is the strangest and the most
frightening
as cp 1678-c known as
the wretch the wretch has only ever been
encountered outside the zone which is
now
under scp foundation control and it's
uncertain how many instances of this
being
exist the wretch resembles an old woman
or sometimes
old man dressed in filthy rags the red
sits at street corners holding a begging
tray
and will attempt to elicit pity from
anyone who happens to walk by
the wretch will ask for food or money
but if food is supplied
it will start weeping before vanishing
into a puff of black smoke
on a few occasions audio notices playing
on the city's loudspeakers have alluded
to this being
saying do not pity the wretch allow them
to pay the price of their betrayal for
all eternity
the current foundation protocol with
regards to the wretch
is to not engage with it at all in
addition to the bobbies
the eyes in the sky and the wretches
there's another strange component to the
world of on london
throughout the city in any area designed
for human habitation
the foundation discovered multiple
machines that resembled modern gas pumps
these machines are fitted with coin
slots and rubber hoses that
when coins are inserted dispense a
porridge-like substance advertised as dr
goody's wonder food according to posters
around the city
wonder food is a meal replacement
supplement supposedly containing all of
the required nutrients for survival
wonder food also appears to be the only
food source available
in on london despite the claims by
various posters around the city that
wonder food contains all the nutrients
you need
and completely restores health and
vitality examination of this substance
has revealed that it
is much like the rest of unlondon
unsuitable for sustaining life
tests have confirmed that wonder food is
a synthetic starch gel heavily enriched
with various minerals
vitamins fats and bulking agents and it
contains artificially engineered dna
helix structures
while it does contain all the elements
required for short-term survival
consuming the product for longer than
six weeks will result in severe
malnutrition
and eventually scurvy further tests have
shown that wonder food also contains
psychoactive properties
the porridge contains a mixture of
unknown molecular compounds
which through regular consumption makes
subjects calmer
less anxious and less likely to resist
authority
it also seems to have been engineered to
cause withdrawal symptoms that set
in if a person stops eating it symptoms
which include headaches and depression
foundation personnel are forbidden to
consume wonder food but the substance is
highly attractive to instances of
scp-1678-b and 1678
c like most things in london the quality
of wonder food varies wildly
with some dispensers putting out a
product that is so degraded that it can
cause sickness
deformities or even death in the
consumer but strangely
the foundation has also recorded a type
of unknown colorful mollusk which feeds
on spillage from the wonder food
dispensers
at present on london is only partially
contained
mobile task forces tau and epsilon 6
have succeeded in establishing a
perimeter around the hyde park district
where they have managed to stop any
incursion from scp-1678-a
even though this is the only area that
is fully under foundation control
explorations have been conducted of
buildings outside that perimeter
the investigations are vital for the
foundation's main purpose in on london
which is figuring out who built it and
exactly what kind of event this
underground mirror city was meant to
prepare for
the interior of the natural history
museum yielded particularly strange
insights into the purpose of on london
for the most part the museum is close to
how it appears in the above ground
but with one key difference the task
force investigating the museum
discovered an exhibit called the fall of
man
exactly where the darwin wing should
have been the exhibit
as its name suggests details the
apocalyptic scenario that would have
theoretically driven people
underground into on london but to
everyone's surprise
its dioramas and displays didn't depict
an asteroid impact
plague or nuclear armageddon to the
foundation task force members
the scenes of destruction depicted in
the exhibit were far
more familiar they recognized the
reptilian form of scp-682
the ordinary-looking brownstone basement
door that serves as a gateway to
scp-2317
and most chillingly the imposing
many-eyed figure
of the scarlet king these were only some
of the known ketter class scps depicted
in the museum exhibit
it was clear that even though the scp
foundation hadn't built this city
whoever did knew a lot about the scp
foundation's activities
it's believed by the foundation that
whoever or whatever created on london
still resides in the houses of
parliament
and the ultimate goal of the task forces
is to infiltrate the building
but in order to do that they will first
need to find where the bobbies are made
and halt their production
it's believed that bryson's home for the
poor is where they originate from
but it's unclear exactly where the
materials to make them come from
nor is it clear just how they're
produced ultimately
the foundation's goal is to catalog the
entire city and
once they have stopped the production of
more bobbies mtf tao4
and epsilon 6 will storm the houses of
parliament and contain whatever force
has created on london
but london is a very big city and
unlondon is just as big so there's no
telling what else they might find
exploring this bizarre location now go
check out
scp-035 the possessive mask and
scp-2935-odef
for more chilling stories from the scp
foundation